so
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
so you might have heard it's not just
bojo leaving this week and it's my last
peters morgan show tonight yeah i think
it went right everybody seems to be
quite nice the crew were amazing i think
yeah we got on with it sorry hold on a
minute sorry what are you doing who are
you
oh you're the pizza man we've been
waiting hours for you do i look like the
pizza oh you be careful with that
photograph that's my prize i've had
enough of this i'm getting the boss on
the phone where is he
right company phone mate sorry
no phone no show nothing this is what
you get for five weeks you're sitting
for him whilst he's on his big yacht
then he gets his private jet and i
mystery roll the titles
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends well i guess
that better go in there and the box
better be tied up so the nation can
breathe finally a huge sigh of relief
the old boy is finally off what a
tumultuous time it's been party's galore
a general air of shambolic chaos and
confusion and the perennial whiff of
scandal yes it's the final edition of
piers morgan and censor with me jeremy
carl what else could i be talking about
for goodness sake judging though from
this tweet from piers it's not just
boris he'll be delighted to see the back
of but one line we may have to get used
to hearing over the coming months from
team bojo is that it was the people who
overwhelmingly gave the pm his mandate
back in 2019 yet it was a small group of
bitter mps who ended up throwing him out
just a message for you morgan i'd be
getting on very well with your crew and
your team just saying big man but how
true is this feeling about boris johnson
what are people out there in the united
kingdom think about this man we went
outside talk tv towers to find out how
you
see boris johnson's legacy and yes by
the way we did warn them this was airing
before the watershed take a look
so how would you describe boris
johnson's time as prime minister the
worst there has been no worse prime
minister i think it definitely my
lifetime hasn't been five yes if i had
to describe boris johnson's times
prominence i would say it's
underwhelming i think he did a really
good job got us through the pandemic
well
very bizarre absolutely dismal
just horrendous
absolutely horrendous and a massive
waste of time he had a lot to deal with
and i feel a bit sorry for him to be
fair i think boris was a useless liar
boris johnson's time as prime minister
in a sentence well i can say it in a
word
hilarious
so what is boris johnson's legacy talk
to his political educate mccann is here
along with former labour mp luciano
virgil ah kate i start with you um
what is boris johnson's legacy from a a
political analyst like yourself um i
sort of think politics will never be as
fun again but on a serious note is there
a legacy or was it tarnished beyond
repair
well i think the big worry for boris
johnson and you can see it a little bit
in his last couple of weeks in office is
that he's not quite sure what his legacy
is going to be i mean covert 19 made it
really difficult for him to achieve some
of those things he talked about on the
steps of downing street and look you
heard from people there really mixed bag
but people have strong opinions about
him and about what he achieved he set
out to do something that was quite
unique he managed to harness votes from
a group of people in the country that
very rarely come the conservatives way
and the thing that always sticks in my
mind about boris johnson is the night
after he won that election he came back
and he said look i know that i've
essentially borrowed your votes and i
know that i need to deliver for you or
you will never vote for my party again
he understood the implications of it and
the pressure on him and i think for him
he will be frustrated and probably a
little bit sad that he's not been able
to deliver fully on the things that he
pledged and that would have been cost of
living it would have been so-called
leveling up now we've seen some of that
in new railways we've seen some of that
in new money but even there there have
been accusations that perhaps it's not
gone as far as it should have perhaps
it's been a little bit hollow and it may
well not change the lives of people in
the way that he wants it to so jeremy
what will it be
boris johnson wants it to be the green
agenda now and ukraine i think
potentially ukraine may stick in a lot
of people's minds
listen um
a huge uh critic of boris johnson we'll
talk more about how you left your party
the man that johnson uh defeated in 2019
anybody could have defeated jeremy
corbyn though couldn't they to be fair
um i mean it was it was
all but uh
foregone conclusion that um
certainly at that election that
foreign conservatives were going to win
and boris did so off the back of saying
he was going to get right but i mean
that's an interesting one i've said this
to kate before privately i mean i'm not
a marketing guru or or a political
analyst but i remember the night 2019
election really clearly the liberal
democrats said we're not going to do
what the british people the majority of
the british people want the labour party
said we haven't got a clue what we're
going to do and all he had to say was
get brexit done
that was done covered very very quickly
i always use this example and i'm gonna
throw this at you straight away i had
somebody on the radio today and i can't
swear so i won't but he basically said
boris johnson is a lying whatever but he
is my lying whatever now this man
despite his flaws despite the lack of
attention to detail his rather shady
relationship with the truth that we all
know
still to this day resonates with the
british people and we talked to fair
none of us would be surprised if he
didn't make a comeback i think it
resonates with some british people um
but certainly his popularity has
decreased significantly since when he
first came into office and you know the
gap in the polls now is the greatest
that it's ever been so yes that was
certainly the case when he when he came
in in 2019 that is not the case now uh
and we have to only look at his record
and what he is on what do you remember
him for um and what he hasn't done to
see why that is the case and i think you
know in my mind he's brought the office
of being a prime minister into disrepute
i mean you know when else in our history
have we seen what we've seen just
looking at what happened with party gate
victoria but what do you say to the
people i bring kate in as well what do
you say to the people across europe and
the world who are in complete
i don't know confusion that we got rid
of a democratically elected prime
minister who won a a massive majority in
2019 because he had a piece of cake what
do you say to that but it was it was
more than just a piece of a cake it was
a
you can call it just a piece of cake it
was many pieces of cake it wasn't just
one piece of cake it was many people
enjoying the cake and what is what it
symbolized to the british people who i
think have a very strong sense of
justice and fairness at a time when
people had to make massive massive
sacrifices people were not allowed to
mourn people not allowed to go you know
not allowed to be with their families
and their friends not allowed to
associate and here who was a man who's
behind closed doors behind the gates of
uh downing street was having parties
with you know living at large when
people couldn't
enjoy those those things that we
normally take for granted and it was it
was a sense of injustice i think an
offense that people to but you know it
wasn't just a piece of cake i think
that's a really interesting way to
describe it a sense of injustice and yet
during this ridiculous long-winded tory
leadership thing that's gone on for
about seven years it seems and we have a
new prime minister on monday we'll talk
about that in a sec
frighteningly to think that 70-something
percent of the conservative membership
if his name was on the ballot would
still be voting for boris johnson so has
his popularity gone
well i think this has a lot to do with
the difference between how the
conservative party in the country so
conservative members and the
conservative party in westminster feel
they don't necessarily feel the same way
not about what they want out of a leader
and certainly not about their own prime
minister about boris johnson now that's
been the case for a while and there are
some in the tory party who've recognized
that and have tried to bring the two
closer together and fix it but they
haven't succeeded and that's a
fundamental problem for whoever gets
into number 10 next it's probably going
to be list trust because the party has
got used to this idea of chaos and
remember there's a whole new load of mps
who came in in 2019 who are not wedded
to the conservative party structure they
are not bound by a sense of duty or by
any sense really that they have to wait
their turn for a ministerial job they
feel emboldened emboldened by winning in
seats where the party never won before
and crucially they feel like that's down
to them and that's given them the
freedom to act out if you like and
behave in a different way and that split
between the party and the country and
the party in westminster is problematic
that's very true luciano also one of the
things that i hear repeatedly from from
from tories is is not about his behavior
far more traditional right-wing tory
voters complained that he didn't deliver
the tory manifesto that the traditional
tory things lowering taxes he was hell
bent on a green agenda he seemed to
concentrate on things that aren't
traditional tory voters now kate's
absolutely right the tory party is in
turmoil we have sunnah called trust
every poll points to liz trust becoming
the prime minister on monday uh sunak
will not accept a job because she'll
offer him something that's not good
enough what becomes of the tory party
because i guess your ex-employers the
labour party should be rubbing their
hands with glee but i still find it
astonishing by the way that they're only
13 points in front they should be out of
sight shouldn't they by now well it was
15 points
i called into the you go and i salute
you for walking out on that lot because
corbin was an absolute disgrace
genuinely yeah and and i it was every
good reason why i left the labour party
back uh in february of 2019. and i i
mean just to answer your question i
think part of the challenge is that
on what he pledged
boris johnson did not deliver
on so many fronts
you know you touched on like leveling up
you have to look at the most recent gcse
results to see the disparity between the
you know the north and the south whether
it was all the hospitals that he said he
was going to you know be building you
know that's gone to the wayside the
festival of brexit which we find out
today that cost millions of pounds uh
and again to deliver there's a litany of
things that you know he did pledge and
if you make a promise an election
manifesto you have to
who do you fear most trust or sunni well
it's going to be this trust like every
poll points in that we're not allowed to
say that because we have to do straight
down the line but every poll says it
will be liz trust she's the continuity
candidate isn't she they're both
continuity candidates they both sat
around the cabinets i don't understand i
did you know kate i'll bring you into
this you lot of political you know
you're you're high high flyers i don't i
think the tory a party is a really
strange beast right they waited months
for somebody to be courageous enough to
stand up and basically with the greatest
respect stick a blade between boris
johnson's shoulder blades but whoever
did that was never going to be trusting
that comes out and every hustings and it
comes out in every poll when he resigns
sooner right having supported all these
things that people disagree with it
folded like a deck of cards didn't it
and he would never be trusted by the
traditional tourists so i i think i
think the labour party what do you make
of the labour party under kierstama then
i think you see the labour party making
massive strides to first of all actually
come up with kind of proper plans you
know what we've heard from the labour
party just in the last few weeks a plan
which we should have had from this
government we should have had from boris
johnson in his last few weeks we should
have had parliament parliaments
in advance of the off gem um paris cap
the energy price cap rising um as it did
at the end of last week and what we have
at least from a party a party of
opposition under the leadership of sir
kirsten would you rejoin them is it
probably costed i'm not allowed to
rejoin no but in two years time would
you rejoin him with kia stammer in
charge instead of that anti-semite
jeremy corbyn um let's see what happens
in two years time it's it's you know
it's uh it's academic for this moment in
time
okay quick question um we know about
monday the queen is not going to receive
her new prime minister uh 15th prime
minister in buckingham palace it's going
to be in balmoral um
the priorities for the new prime
minister i mean who'd want the job this
country is broken the energy crisis the
cost everything i mean it's a it's a
pretty hard task isn't it forever takes
over
it's going to be a mammoth task and the
most difficult thing for liz trust if it
is liz trust and as you say the polls
point in that direction is that she has
spent the last however many weeks making
quite significant promises to the
conservative party members which have
been heard by the rest of the country
and she may well find it difficult to
deliver on
hardly any of them because of the scale
of what she's going to have to do she's
going to have to tackle energy prices
that will be her first major
intervention but there's also food
prices inflation and remember every
decision she makes could potentially
fuel inflation some people saying some
experts saying it could be 22 by next
year everything feeds everything else if
you help for example those at the lower
end with energy bills but not those in
the middle classes who maybe could get
through it well they might stop spending
they might stop going out to pubs and
restaurants stop spending on clothes and
we know those businesses are really
struggling too the government can't help
everyone trust has been clear about that
but essentially that's what she's going
to be asked to do and she's going to
have to find a way to navigate that
alongside everything else including the
ukraine and that very quickly is what i
find astonishing because sunak if you
strip it down is a more traditional
torii in terms of he's talking about
prudence and he's saying we can't make
promises and we can't do that and yet
they're seemingly going for that
continuity candidate but this speaks
speaks again to what we've seen from the
conservatives over the last 12 years
because that's how long they've been in
office yeah you know we are in this
crisis at this moment in time i was a
former shadow energy minister for three
years between 2010 and 2013. and we
didn't as a country do what we should
have done to save for when it rains and
we're in this absolute crisis now
because we have this over reliance on
foreign imported gas we haven't seen the
investment that we should have had in
nuclear we're an island we've got wind
that blows we've got tidal power which
would be using solar the whole thing
we could be powering millions of homes
we could have done so much to internet
we've uh properties across the uk we've
got some of the most leaky properties
across europe we could have seen
millions of people not spending money
which just escapes through their door
and that's why we're in such a dire
situation now with you know we're facing
inflation
listen it's it's we've done this every
single night and and i say to both of
you we've done it every single night
about broken britain and the cost of
living crisis and you get to a point
where you feel what more can we say
people are are struggling and and it's
not just those on on lower incomes i
talk about the jams every single night
they're just about managing people who
pay all their bills and do all that and
are struggling hard hard times but etc
the head of ads said come january 50 of
households in this country boris said
buy a kettle what no we'll be spending
more than 10 percent or more of our
disposable income on our energy bills
this is not just about yeah
i agree about the whole country i'm
going to ask you both what i ask the
good people of the united kingdom one
word kate mccann in your mind personal
opinion sums up boris johnson
you can't ask me that that's impossible
to answer in one word especially in a
personal opinion which you know full
well i'm not allowed to well just give
one word
difficult interesting you see that
doesn't that doesn't get you into any
trouble i like the jacket very much one
word devastating
devastating i would say unique thank you
very much indeed luciana thank you very
much indeed kate mccann next to an
uncensored broken britain we've been
talking about it the country in a mess
and frankly the only thing on the up is
the crime rates the one thing today i
was reading the paper because the
decline of the traditional family unit
in any way be responsible for what's
happening in the country we'll discuss
that next after this break we're coming
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much today welcome back
to uncensored now a new report out today
shows that 23 of britain's 8.2 million
families consist of only one parent and
get this
49 of children living in lone parent
families are in relative poverty
compared with just 25 of those living in
married or cohabiting families during my
time on the show we have repeatedly and
quite rightly i believe focused on
broken britain a country in a mess with
crime running rampant masked men
fighting with four-foot machetes in
leeds
an armed robbery in broad daylight in
west london from the shocking murder of
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell in
liverpool now as well as talking about
broken britain we've just been talking
about its causes uh and actually one of
the real causes it says in a newspaper
article today could indeed be the social
decay is it staring us in the face is
the breakdown of the traditional family
unit part of the reason have a look at
this
and they're thugs they are the scum of
the earth and they take firearms out
onto the streets and poor olivia rest
her soul is the victim of that the issue
is that we have an element of
criminality which i would say is more of
an issue that relates to poverty a cost
of living crisis the scale of the crisis
that is about to engulf us both
customers consumers ordinary general
public and the businesses is so immense
people on universe are correct if
they're young they get less than 300
pounds a month that's not enough to
carry their electricity bill
i have a very dysfunctional family of my
own to discuss this in the uncensored
studio a campaign director at the
conservative group citizen go caroline
farrow welcome uh talk tv legend mike
graham and political journalist ava
santina um can i start with you uh
caroline um
it seems particularly unfair to label
one parent families is the cause of the
problems in this country doesn't it yeah
i would agree actually i would push back
against any gross generalization um but
it doesn't if if you look at the stats
um and nobody's destined to be a
statistic but being brought up in a
one-parent family
makes it your your chances of being
involved in crime of uh being of having
low exam grades um of being homeless
they're all doubled and that's
absolutely true yeah it's not just a
made-up
no that that that was because i know
many many many people from one parent
families who have been given the most
loving caring honestly i know many
people from families of people who have
argued non-stop and their kids are
affected by that
that well that's right you can't
generalize and i think we all know of of
one parent families where the mother or
the father has been an absolute heroine
or hero but if you just think about it
objectively and and this is it's very
difficult to talk about this because
people tend to think that you are
blaming or shaming or trying to you know
ascribe blame to people and very often
people in one parent families it's not
that oh you know it's not through their
own doing this is not necessarily
something they've chosen but look at it
objectively and i know this from my own
experience and i've been a single parent
myself it is so much harder raising
children by yourself when you're just
one pair of hands but then to read
statistics you told my team there's a
lot more instances of mental health
problems in children from untraditional
families and they don't do well at
school that's a sweeping generalization
isn't it that that isn't quite the
generalization i made but when we were
talking when i was talking to the
research team yes it is true that
children who come from single parent
families are more likely to experience
mental health problems and the the
outcomes for them are not so good but
that does not force anybody to become a
statistic
so that research is from the center for
social justice and and the report that
was uh released today but isn't the
problem really now about sort of
ability and about parents and how good
if you've got one parent who's brilliant
then you're going to be fine uh if
you've got a parent who's a criminal uh
you're probably going to be a criminal
what is a traditional family bud well
luckily contributed in many ways to this
particular debate personally by having
children within a marriage children
outside of a marriage i've lived with
with the mother of my children i've been
separated from people you know when i
get to fill out that form where it says
you know what are you single married
divorced i don't even know what to take
everybody don't just go everything yeah
thanks i'll take it all
you know the point is it's all about if
you've got two parents who are separated
and you're technically being raised in a
single parent household it doesn't mean
you're going to suddenly go off the
rails i mean i think what we're talking
about here is class we're talking about
opportunity we're talking about
education and we're talking about in the
end you tend to do what your parents do
see that's the point isn't it and who
can say that one parent isn't a role
model i know as i say plenty of people
brought up in the most horrendous
situations where they're at each other's
throats and patently the kid would have
been better served if they'd been you
know separated parents and they'd visit
them each what's your view on them
definitely i mean like nuclear family
when we talk about that it's basically
like a narrow template where for some
reason we still think that a mother and
a father and two children is the best
way to run things but you're right
arguments in a household are horrendous
i know i think that
i actually find the idea of a nuclear
family quite um
backwards i actually find it real i
don't think we should go that far well i
do i do i i think myself she wants to
revolutionize everything no no no but
look listen i mean we can say that we
shouldn't be tarnishing single families
with all your kids are going to be
criminals fail at school but we then
shouldn't say that the traditional
family right doesn't i'll give you an
example my parents were married for 60
years and i used to say to her this is
genuinely true you say do you argue with
him she said honest to god she said i
went deaf after six months she said to
me but the way we were brought up we
stuck around and we got our heads down
and we had kids and that has changed
that people do walk quicker and i'd yes
i think you have to look at the
statistics as well so when we just look
if we're wanting society to be better
and we're wanting outcomes to be better
for children we know from looking at all
the research all the statistics all the
studies that children who are raised by
both biological parents have a much
better chance of doing well in life
but it's not because it's not because of
the fact that they're being raised by
biological parents it's because of the
place that they come from tends to be a
better place so what you're doing is
you're taking a group of statistics and
you turn them on their head what you
should be saying is actually the reason
why people who don't do as well as they
do is because of where they've come from
it so happens that many of their parents
have split up
i don't know but but i think you also
have to remember is that when parents
are you know
when you've got a mum and a dad you've
got you know two people who've
biologically parented that child and
they are together and they have got the
you know they've both got the child's
best interests at heart
again you can't say i'm sorry i i
consider myself as good a parent as as
the women i've had children with and i
don't understand how you're saying that
if if you stay together that that makes
you a better parent i'm i'm as good a
parent
no but nobody is saying but you've just
said that two biological parents being
together gives a kid a better chance to
completely disagree with that but but
that's what the statistics show
statistics that's why statistics are
pointless you know boris johnson's
parents stood up at a very early age
he's been prime minister of this country
you know he didn't do badly for himself
he might say not much of a parent
himself because he follows his parents
but he didn't do badly as a result of
being raised in a single parent
household well i think when you when you
look at the research that is actually
showing i don't like research i just
don't like it because you can twist it
but then we all talk we all talk about
evidence-based research yeah and policy
yeah it doesn't mean anything but policy
should be basically are you saying that
if if a couple stay together and are
married their kid is going to have a
better chance of life statistically well
you keep saying statistically i mean
sorry i don't see that what else
when we're talking about policy and when
we're talking about attitudes
when we're talking about children and
our society's future and and how do we
make things better then actually we do
have to look at the evidence and we do
have to look at the research and at the
moment you know there's kind of a
mindset where people think oh yeah what
happens in school you know that matters
and you know
poverty which of course is a huge huge
huge factor if you grow up in a
two-parent household biological parents
and you haven't got any money and you go
to a terrible school you're obviously
going to turn out badly and you're
living in a state where you might get
stabbed to death so
how do we then how do we we've got you
know a couple in poverty how do we make
life better for the couple in poverty to
be able to raise their children give
them social mobility which has
disappeared in this country which used
to exist
you do away with public schools for a
start and you can't put kids in public
schools and then everybody goes to the
same school and everybody starts to get
to know each other and there's no strata
in society i'm a bit naive okay i i and
we're in the middle of a crisis that's
affecting
major swathes of this country i'm still
naive enough to believe that everybody
should and hopefully gets an opportunity
but there is absolute proof i'm not
going to say research because i tend to
agree with mike on this a lot i believe
that the
to that that research that sweeping
generalization is an insult to many many
millions of decent single parents and
it's also an insult to kids who are
brought up in a single parent family and
who have gone on and made something of
their life because trust me i know many
people from my ex-life who stay together
and have kid after kid with absolutely
no dis no regardless i'll tell you what
i do think i think traditional family
values when you are in that unit
sometimes could be a lot better but that
could be a single parent or two parents
together same sex couple same sex
we have to look at this objectively okay
you know because everybody has their own
emotional baggage and their own
emotional stake to bring to this but
saying look ex situation is
statistically better than my situation
is not the same as actually kind of
dissing on a whole section of society
i've said all along nobody is destined
to be a statistic but if you know that
certain situation is going to be better
for children then why don't you
incentivize this situation incentivize
people to stay together when they don't
get on no i think i think we can do a
lot what do you make of singles
same sex relationship i thought i
thought we'd get onto onto this i think
what adults choose to do uh is
consenting adults choose to do is up to
them however what i would say is and and
i'm very clear on this and it will get
your eye out i do not agree with taking
uh babies away from their mothers oh you
know i feel very strongly where are you
taking bait where are you couples no
wait wait wait wait babies
where you have two men who are having a
baby where is that babe where does that
baby come from from any number of places
what do you mean what do you mean so
okay
how do you make a baby
okay i understand the biology but you
say like a child who's been adopted that
that's not a valid problem the thing no
i'm saying that where you have a
situation where a child has been adopted
or removed from its parents that you
know child has been removed from its
parents do you believe in two parents
parenting and giving love and if two men
can give that to which you know where's
the mother where is them we again we
know that young young babies need their
mothers and you only remove a baby from
their mother
the mother
they're removed i've changed more
nappies than you've had
it's about love and it's about love too
men too women can give that love i'm not
i'm not deceived i don't really know
that jerry nobody's saying that two men
can't give a cup but you're saying where
is it you're talking about a baby's
needs
you've been talking a lot the point is
this nobody takes a child away from its
mother many of the mothers who provide a
child for a same-sex couple have done so
willingly they've decided to be a
surrogate mother and they've done it out
of their own choice which that's
perfectly exciting to do i'm sorry if
you don't like it but that's their
choice right people have freedom of
choice lots of children are abandoned by
their mothers because either they can't
handle it or because they're mentally
not not well enough to look after them
they go to adoption plenty of people get
adopted and have very successful lives
they do you know so you talk about women
having children literally ripped away
from them it's bonkers nobody does that
it's absolutely not i'm
adoption is at least worst option okay
adoption can i tell you one of the
things that i could talk about from now
to the end of time but i haven't we have
the most antiquated adoption lord in the
world there are thousands of children
and will disagree on this
there are thousands of children in this
country who should be adopted these
people that go did you know what our
laws are ridiculous and i think and
maybe i'm wrong a loving parent on its
own that's what we started about two of
the same sex loving that's fine i go
about traditional family values i think
a lot of those have dissipated but those
values can be part of a one parent
family and a two parent family and the
same sex family it's down to the parents
isn't it they can but where you have a
child in need of a home a child has lost
a mother and a father we'll have to
agree to disagree but listen you know
listen everybody is inside that you're
looking absolutely no this is because
we're just demonizing we're demonizing
same-sex couples are there no we're not
you're
sex couples going and rip children away
from others
no it's not mental i think where you
have where you have two men raising a
baby that baby has come from a mother
you have removed and whatever means
listen breastfeed two men
i'm sorry i'm sorry timeout it's my luck
time out you can continue backstage
ladies thank you very much indeed mike
and i it's the only time in our lives
and we said very little right next to
uncensored here's a good one should
smart motorways and speed limits be
scrapped if liz trust as expected
becomes our next prime minister on
monday they might well be is she right
we'll do that after the break we're
coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
thank you very much eddie welcome back
now as part of a final appeal to tory
members liz trust suggested scrapping
smart motorways now i want you to listen
to this excerpt from a 999 call from a
family who broke down on one and just a
warning some of you might find this
distressing
i'm stuck in the middle of the m6 my
car's broken down i passed knutsford um
i'm going northbound
got the hazards on
uh what else can i do because i'm i've
got a family of five in the car okay
don't worry
and you say there's five people in the
car yeah my my oh
[Applause]
hello
hello
unbelievable thankfully i have to tell
you nobody was killed in that accident
but joining me now is claire mercer who
has campaigned so strongly for smart
motorways to be scrapped since her
husband jason was tragically killed on
the m1 um claire thank you so much adee
for joining us on uncensored
tell us your story if you'd be so kind
um yeah jason had
what should have just been a minor
incident on the motorway on the way to
work one morning him and another
motorist minor bump
but where it happened was a sign saying
no hard shoulder for four miles it
didn't give any other information
they couldn't get their vehicles out of
the live running lane because of the
crash barrier and they couldn't get over
the crash barrier because of 30 foot
drop onto the road below
so they were hemmed in basically they
were stood in a live lane with their
vehicles that they couldn't get out of a
live lane and
a htv hit them and killed them instantly
um
for your loss i'm so sorry um when you
who has fought so long
to have this
ridiculous system
um cancelled you must be delighted to
hear that the well the favor to be the
next prime minister wants to scrap them
what's your response to that
um yes it's good to hear um
i don't trust the word of somebody that
is campaigning for a job that they
really really want you know i i don't
believe they're going to do everything
they say they're going to do
and
but it's interesting that it's been
picked up by both candidates as a
vote-winning bargaining chip
what hurt was her dismissing it as an
experiment the smart motorways
experiment has failed
you know our loved ones got killed in
that experiment you know
do they really have to experiment with
people's lives
but it's interesting that it's been
picked up as a vote winner well you know
it's it's interesting and and you have
obviously real
emotional interest in this story but
you're right it's interesting how many
people uh are questioning the sorts of
things that are being said repeatedly uh
by the candidates but your
your desire and your wish is that the
smart motorways should be
cancelled forthwith right
yes yeah i mean they can call it what
they like they can
there's a lot about saving face and a
lot about excusing the money they've
already spent on this failure but i
don't care what you call it we just need
a hard shoulder on every single motorway
claire thank you for now i'm joined uh
by um mike rawson former road traffic
cop and steve berry former top gear
presenter um help me out mike these are
ridiculous things smart motorways aren't
they
they're almost unbelievable
jeremy when you think
since 1959
we built these motorways we've always
had a hard shoulder
it's the most important safety feature
on a high speed road
and the the planners in 1959 when they
built the m1 between london and
birmingham
they realized there are no junctions no
roundabouts no traffic lights
no farm vehicles no cyclists no
pedestrians
what is there for the motorist to do
and the biggest danger
is the stopped vehicle
in the
in the live lane that's why
they spent the money on putting in hard
shoulders because it's a major safety
feature but jeremy
nobody claims
that it's a hundred percent safe
environment but i tell you one thing
it's a jolly site safer than being
stopped in the path of a forty ton
arctic doing 56 miles an hour steve i i
freely admit you know when i started
this five weeks ago i'm delighted to say
i've learned an awful lot this is
ludicrous man how are people how did
anybody ever think who sat down and when
he listened to that woman's story oh do
you know it's a really good idea if you
break down there's nowhere to go you are
a sitting duck yeah
how did anyone ever think it was i had
about six months ago you probably
haven't spent much time on the odd
shoulder in the swanky motors that you
thought about him
i had a bit of a problem in my big old
citroen i was batting a long flat tire
no any car no matter how old or young or
reliable or unreliable can catch a flat
i had time to get over onto the hard
shoulder then get out of the vehicle as
they advise you to do when they're
telling you on one hand to get out of
the vehicle on the hard shoulder and get
over the arm corn to the other side but
they're also saying oh yeah smart
motorways of the future well they're the
opposite ends of the safety spectrum so
what is you've talked about speed limits
what is what is the future i mean we all
agree quite paintly listening to her
story listening to that terrible
terrible audio that there need to be
hard shoulders for people what
absolutely how do people need to drive
better what what's the answer what's
this speed limit debate
well we've had a speed limit in this
country since 1965 when it was brought
in as a temporary measure a bit like
they brought in income tax as a
temporary measure it's still with us
nearly 60 years later the 70 mile an
hour speed limits as old as me and you
make 1965 i think we should go faster
well think about the cars that came out
in 65. the wolseley 1100 a triumph 1300
and the peel trident which is like a
kinder egg on wheels they would struggle
those three cars through 70 miles an
hour and think about the advances
not just in technology but in safety
back then cross-fly tyres drum brakes
and the structural integrity of the
brown paper bag with a damp bottom now
every family car is absolutely solid as
wrong tell them
tell that story about you in germany
when you're on the autobahn quickly well
everybody knows that in germany the
autobahns are unrestricted and when do
they have more accidents no they have if
you take it as accidents per mile or
kilometers they prefer yeah which is the
only way to do it germany and the uk
have a very similar record when it comes
to uh road traffic accidents i went out
there to test the bmw superbike got it
on the autobahn i thought i wonder if
this is speed restricted got it up to
155 miles an hour and
saw the flashing lights and uh the siren
and thought oh i'm getting pulled yeah i
was getting pulled for going too slow in
the fast lane 155 miles an hour yeah
because as he was literally on the hard
shoulder and you do have out shoulders a
porsche came in 175. well we we we all
agree there should be a hard shoulder
another thing liz trust has said she
hits the she will act the motorway speed
in it what's your response to that as
the next traffic up you've heard what
steve has said cars have changed people
need to move on what's your view steve
is quite right about cars survivability
in vehicles today is incredible compared
to years ago
seat belts airbags side impact bars have
made
you know surviving
hugely different to how it used to be
but
i'm sorry the standard of driving today
partly because there's little or no
police enforcement anymore
well they're too busy doing the macarena
okay we've got smart motorways put signs
up 60 on the inside line where all the
trucks can only do 60. 90 in the middle
unrestricted i would like to say
something you're an ex traffic cop
you're a top gear presenter you'll just
laugh at me i think that as many people
cause accidents on motorways by going
slow in the middle lane and people have
to weave in and weave out i'm with him i
don't think the standard of of driving
is anywhere near what it used to be i
mean you can i can't does it for you
jeremy i just that worries me as well
you can buy an electric car that you
don't have to drive just got a new audi
and drove that not bought it but
borrowed it as a press car
late it's got lane finder or minder as
they call it stays in its lane it's got
proximity sensors that keep it a safe
distance from the car in front the thing
was even warning me if it thought cars
coming up behind me or either left or
the right so you would raise speed
limits yes you would cancel smart
motorways because we all agree the lack
of a hard shoulders logics and you would
what would you increase the speed limit
too like i said a variable trucks can
only do six thick yeah 60 in the inside
lane 90 in the middle name unrestricted
in the outside lane come on last word
from you mike
well i'm afraid
we have a 70 limit for a reason now most
people or many people will go up to 80.
i think if we raise it to 80 they'll do
90. now
that is is fast and and yes for steve
and for lots of drivers who are very
good
and anticipate and they use their
mirrors yeah that's fine but sadly we've
got so many poor drivers on the road
just saving a few minutes on the journey
is going to cost a few lives and
i'm all for safety um listen guys thank
you so much today can i say a big thank
you to claire mercer for joining us and
sharing her story also steve berry there
and mike rawson that is a story that
will go on and on but i don't think
anybody watching this would not think
that smart word away should be scrapped
those horrendous stories they need to be
back right next and uncensored by god i
think he's got it just as he's leaving
us
bojo thinks he's worked out the solution
to the energy crisis and frankly martin
know she could be out of a job soon do
not go anywhere because you won't want
to miss what bojo said to cure the whole
problem we're back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back my friends before the break
i told you our current pm uh until
monday thinks he's worked out the
solution to the energy crisis just as
he's leaving office uh all it takes
apparently watch this is to buy a new
kettle if you have an old kettle
that takes ages to boil it may cost you
20 pounds to replace it
but if you get a new one you'll save 10
pounds a year for every
year on your
ten pounds a year every year on your
electricity bill
joined again by mike graham over santina
in the legend that is demographic very
quickly people i mean god honestly he
has no idea how much a kettle cost won
he's probably never ever boiled a kettle
no and also i thought at one point he
was talking about one of his ex-wives
there about the young the old boiler
that didn't work i mean what's going on
with boris why is he doing this farewell
tour it's ridiculous i'm going to defend
him oh yeah she does this for a
reaction is what happens right this is
what happens the lefties are all ended
up defending boris johnson
he was making a point about nuclear
energy about how you need to invest in
it right in the same way that you need
to invest in a kettle in the way
labour the coalition government failed
invest
that
to invest in it i actually think he was
making can i just say i haven't achieved
a lot in my career but i have in five
short weeks turned over santina into a
celebrity sort of fan of boris johnson
gemma i think it is the biggest insult
if it's an analogy okay but if it's
actual general financial advice to
families who are set to spend half of
their income on energy it's just not i
mean ten pounds is absolutely nothing i
mean they really families are struggling
gonna have three million people that are
going to fall into poverty the bill is
three thousand five hundred pounds per
year apparently
go away
okay still three thousand five hundred
pounds so much to deal with here uh one
word we did this earlier on the streets
one word to describe boris johnson's
legacy gemma it's over that's two
words with an apostrophe iii
i say brexit
machiavellian
mine is frustration
because i think there was a great chance
and he blew it uh haven holiday mascots
this is brilliant now the seaside squad
characters have been names have been
rebranded bradley bear becomes a
gender-neutral renamed jazz uh anxious
the elephant and greedy the guerrilla of
name changes to annie and george
speculated to avoid defending the
nervous and the overweight mike graham
yeah well i'm not frightened by the
greedy greedy gorilla uh i'm i i would
be one of the people apparently they're
trying to help because they don't want
me to think of him as fat
and the anxious uh elephant i mean who
cares really i mean have you been to
haven holiday i took my kids there oh i
mean there's a lot more frightening
things at haven holidays including the
places where you're made to sleep
including the food that they give you
including the state living pool horrible
another lawsuit well i think if this was
the other way around and we'd rename
them anxious elephant or whatever you'd
all be complaining that we've all gone
soft and we care too much about mental
health and everyone's too in touch
there's somebody inside it dressed as a
pink elephant it's not really anxious
gemma godfrey doesn't just do financial
advice very quickly the haven holiday
thing in terms of mascots i understand
about moving things gender neutral but
taking away the emotion i agree it's
actually better to have the emotion
there and encourage children to talk
about their emotions than just say we
don't have a motion to talk so we don't
offend anybody it's quite good to talk
about yeah i mean children don't really
know if you call something the anxious
elephant they don't go why is it anxious
they don't care it's not what the
anxious is elephant
um
resolution foundation analysts have
decided today that real household
disposable incomes will plummet by 10
over this year and next that's 3 000
pounds for the typical family yeah but
it's also not just about families
disposable income um is used to spend
it's going to hit restaurants it's going
to hit pubs it's going to hit shops and
if that happens then it's going those
companies are going to fire people so
actually it's not just about people not
having disposed enough disposable income
anymore and not having an emergency fund
but it's also gonna hit jobs and hit
livelihoods and i think that's why it's
such a terrible thing we have talked and
thank you so much for joining us over
the past five weeks you've been amazing
we've talked about these problems and
we've tried to give constructive hints
just just very briefly because i've got
much time what would you say to people
watching this as we finish our run here
uh if i try and pick something that we
haven't talked about before one of the
things is smart meters might be quite a
good play because but there's talk not
just about smart meters giving you
discounts but also you could end up
being paid if you actually switch off
your high energy usage um appliances at
certain times there's also drafts
excluders it's the cheapest and the most
effective way to insulate your house and
to save on your energy bills um and also
you know there's a lot about don't pay
your energy bills but if you do that you
can end up with fees and arrears as well
do you worry about we haven't got much
time do you worry about what's coming
yeah of course of course i do everyone's
worried about it i'm worried most about
what you've just said about people on
higher pay packets not having any
disposable income and people losing
their jobs i mean if you were a real
small c conservative you'd be out
funding this because what was the point
in funding all of those small businesses
throughout the pandemic pouring all that
money in only for them to have to turn
the lights out because of energy bills
and they still haven't bounced back yet
all those bounce back loans they still
have to pay back they're not yet on
their feet so this is even worse than
the pandemic i would love to paint a
better picture 10 seconds mikey it's not
great for people is it it really isn't
and it will get worse but i mean i'm
always an optimist about these things
and we will get through it you know
there are things that go wrong you just
have to deal with it
can i say um to you three my favorite
people gemma and mike and ava what's it
can i say
right what's that
he's off
as morgan boards his private jets having
got off his yachts uh that is it from me
the main man is back apparently on
monday it's been a real pleasure i can't
even say that probably and a privilege i
don't know if i'll see you again but if
i don't it's been an absolute joy um for
the final time
[Music]
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did his interview
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora suleiman police
have released new cctv footage of the
man they believe murdered olivia pratt
corbell her killer can be seen fleeing
the scene in liverpool on monday last
week after fatally shooting the
nine-year-old in the chest detectives
say they now know two guns were used
boris johnson's pledged 700 million
pounds towards a nuclear power plant in
suffolk he said he's confident the
sizewell sea project will get over the
line in the next few weeks and urged his
successor to go nuclear go large and
more rail misery as the rmt union
announced 40 000 members will strike
this month workers at network rail and
14 train companies will walk out on the
15th and 17th of september that's all
for now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you